no i i have a great deal of respect for
you know there's nobody who's been a
bigger fan than the patriots to me so
um i have nothing but total respect and
love and uh
you know i'm so grateful to mr kraft and
the organization and coach belichick and
all the coaches and obviously all my
teammates
that's tom brady yesterday in his
introductory conference call with the
tampa bay buccaneers chris sims i am
shocked that tom brady said nothing of
any real interest or value during his
entire conference call what what a turn
of events the guy who's been brainwashed
for 20 years into saying absolutely
nothing at any time that anyone is
interested in would say nothing at any
time yesterday that we'd find
interesting
well yeah he he is a robot that way you
know but but in doing it right and you
know just sitting there listening to
this 30-minute phone press conference
which was weird enough as it is when
it's you know the most decorated
greatest quarterback in the history of
the sport type guy doing it on a you
know a phone conference did seem weird
all right so that was that was something
to get used to but listen the one thing
that always stands out to me about tom
brady he just treats everybody with
respect he says all the right things he
deflects any praise to other people when
he talks about bad things or having to
work he talks about himself having to do
what it takes you know he's i understand
why tampa wants it i do i get that he's
gonna rub off on that locker room that's
the first thing he's gonna do the second
thing is
i mean bruce arians we know he's not
there forever and they want to win right
now and he decided hey jameis winston
ain't gonna do it and i might only coach
for two or three more years so i'm gonna
go down swinging with one of the best
ever and that's where it fits and that's
why there's a lot of potential and we're
talking about it so much
one of the things we can count on tom
brady doing in this era of so many
people working at home he will
spearhead the effort to get all of his
receivers all of his offensive linemen
everyone on the same page as needed
he'll go through a series of meetings
he'll do a receivers meeting at
quarterbacks meeting a running backs
meeting an offensive line meeting
throughout the course of the day to make
sure that everyone's on the same page
and they can do it as much as they want
on their own i'm still waiting chris for
the nfl to announce some alternative
plans for the offseason program that
revolves around guys being at home
connected by computer and talking and
working and studying but regardless of
anything the teams have in place brady
will be a guy who i am convinced will
get everyone on the same page get them
all working with whatever playbook there
they get from bruce arians whatever film
they're able to study whatever things
they're able to do he will make the most
out of it because he's so driven to win
no doubt and he's going to be even extra
motivated because of the i just left you
know the new england patriots and i want
to prove that i can win without bill
belichick and add to my legacy so that's
going to let you know lead to a another
level of drive and expectations in his
own mind that he's going to be willing
to reach so yeah that's where it's
amazing and i get why bruce arians and
and jason light everybody wanted tom
brady down there it's good for business
and it does give them a chance to win
right now and be something special we'll
see where that goes now i did find it
kind of awkward and i thought the most
interesting part mike was when he was
asked about mr kraft's comments right
about tom wanted this you know that was
the most awkward part of the press
conference to me and the thing i would
still really like to know you know did
new england not want him did tom not
want to go back we're not really sure
how that all unfolded
and i don't know when we will find it
well look
bill belichick i i don't know how much
of uh how much we balanced this out
bill belichick was ready to move on tom
is ready to move on and there never was
an effort by either to move toward each
other to break the ice both guys kind of
wanted this
and neither guy was willing to make the
first move to make it not happen i think
that's my read on it yeah i i would
agree i think both were content or just
sick of each other you know what
belichick just going damn i'm not gonna
pay him all this money uh you know in
year 20 of his career brady just wants
to be respected have fun i get it i just
think yeah it hit the end of the road
and tom wants a new start
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports